[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
the third party gave long commission to all
that competition
to the greetings sent to all
friends follow them through the 52mx channel
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Applause]
before a fight when I'm
behind the curtain it
's an emotion here between fear then
like the fear is gone and like I
want to embrace use all the
treatments and say thank you I don't
like it less
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music  ]
the cave
[Applause]
why
ah
[Applause]
growing up a dangerous city if there were a
lot of thugs I think that because of the lack
of work that existed in the neighborhood
then I think that since I
was a child my mentality was this that  I have to
learn to defend
[Applause]
In the center there was an arena so I
started to watch the training sessions and well,
I liked it. I didn't have it. I was just going to turn 14
[Applause]
After a year he went with my mom, she
found out that I already m  He went to high school and
only a transfer
but not for that
[Music]
well
[Applause]
I think of a man who struggles later when he
comes home tired he goes to bed and
has his wife you can't do
other things but  Most of the
fighters are single moms and well,
we get home, but the children
still have to go to the chat room and sometimes if
I arrive at around 3 in the morning or 4 in the
morning on
Saturdays and Sundays, people usually
rest and are  when I have more
events
and it is something very difficult to carry because
sometimes I would like to go home and go to
bed but I try to make the
house nice, not so that my daughter is
windy if I have to fight in the kingdom and
fight freaks in the arena  I was there
[Music]
[Applause]
many times the neighborhoods don't have to
pay for that, so I'm very happy to come and
do this work that leads the neighborhoods to fight
person that madonna that looks at you  s shoulders
remove the lock on my face in los
locos
[Music]
I am 14 years old he had an excellent
fight which many irons
a magician is a great fighter and
Latino
if they do me for faith this sport is
for men
[Applause]
[Music  ]
[Music]
is that here we are, there is no one but
the press is interested in them in the
field of wrestling it is difficult for a
woman to startle when
I was training I have always wanted to do it
mortals I think I wanted to do it and
names now we  They helped each other and
ourselves so, yes, when
I came to the district they saw me on television
it hurt for a long time
[Music]
we are talking
my teacher asked me a question I don't know
you want to fight professionally
you want to leave nation the doctor wants to
stay here in the province it's fine  It was difficult to
stand out. I was already separated from
my husband and my son was one year old,
so I began to think, I am not going to
do anything
if
I, my son, well, I always do.  I had with me I
was going to go back with his clothes
only this last time he borrowed them
but there came a time when he no
longer communicated it
so I went to look for him to collect money
and all the mef Euskadi I got there and it
turns out that I had a  native demand
for my work of that fighter
I could not have my son with me
because I hope and God touches his heart of my
ex-husband and allows me one day to see him I
have not seen this book in four years
I remember that this day  I
took it to the arena, a collection that is tender to
know
and just as he removes it, they do not make their
signs like that with them, it
is a constant fight and it is one
every morning, I do not always ask God to
give me strength because I have had achievements in
the fight and  I have had achievements as a person
with my daughter but despite all that
there is something here that always hurts me and I feel
that it will never
stop hurting
until they see
it.
nasa and sepsis and they just won
some championships in japan they
came to mexico and we fought
against them
institution
[Applause]
when I was very very nervous very very
nervous I just do whatever I want
[Music]
because the rain is supporting it
and it's  Taking out what fight we are
witnessing that the spectacular technicians are returning
we can talk
when
[Laughs]
[Music]
not much comes out but there is more to
do all hunter
concessions
[Applause]
champion
a mistake of the rough they
took good advantage of the techniques allow
[Applause]
[Music]
and now we weren't very happy
I've always said that
there aren't two of them like Mexican wrestling
[Music]
[Applause]
I still have goals to achieve
because I'm a 40-year-old champion but I want
the championship  world
[Music]
I am
very grateful to wrestling because
I think I would have gone wrong on
my way.
My greatest hope is to see
friends again and I  Luna Mágica helps a lot
because when I feel like this depressed
and stressed in some way, well, not
basic, but from strength, I come to the
gym, I get in the ring and I go back,
like, to load the [ __ ],
but my biggest concern is that it
could hurt me.  because it is a sport with
many risks that I cannot see
my children grow up due to an injury that I have
from an accident they have
and
[Music]
I would not like my daughter to go to chad
now not because it is not good
what happens is that  As a mother, it would hurt me a
lot to see her hit
[Music]
if you know what to study and then if you
want, go ahead, I love them, but I
would tell her that maybe I wouldn't
say no, but if I discourage her
[Music]
the first time I  I fought in the Mexico arena it
was a dream so incredible
incredible on television and at the national level they
didn't know me and I was
behind like that on the side of the screen and I
already all the people and the people were
screaming and I felt like a big show ago
and I remember that they say my name I
look back
and I wanted to tell the teacher that
he was asked that I loved him, it is known that
he always doesn't go out I don't go out but I did
n't tell him I just thought about it and you don't turn around
and tell him  It's that he says let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
we can of the people crazy with emotion
in the ring 24 fought their idols of the
mission while the caveman we can and the
world
felt inflamed without ceasing
vettel has returned put the person in him
Excuse me, I want to go to the mailbox, it will not be
delighted if we want, we like
[Music]
and